denn vor dem times square in new york
steht jetzt unser kollege herbert
bauernebel hallo herbeth am morgen soll
das im pitch mit verfahren gegen staaten
es ist ja das zweite wir sind diesmal
die aussichten auf erfolg bildern kann
man sehen wie explosiv die stimmung
insgesamt ist in den usa nancy pelosi
die demokratische speakerin des
repräsentantenhauses hat wie gesagt
angekündigt dass es losgehen wird am
montag stehen 200 demokraten bereits
hinter dem schritt das ist also eine
ausgemachte sache es geht dann es muss
dann relativ schnell gehen es bleibt ja
nur mehr wenig zeit übrig das
repräsentantenhaus wird dann abstimmen
über den anklagepunkt der bereits
vorgelegt wurde dann werden im pitch
mend manager bestimmt das sind dann de
facto die ankläger donald trump hat
natürlich seine verteidiger bei diesem
verfahren gehabt wird zurückgreifen auf
rudy giuliani den ehemaligen new yorker
bürgermeister und dann kommt das eigenen
zum eigentlichen verfahren im senat
den vorsitz führt der höchstrichter der
vorsitzende des supreme courts john
roberts das kennt man ja schon vom
ersten engagement verfahren aus dem
vorjahr es gibt dann wie gesagt die
ankläger tragen die anklage vor rudy
giuliani wird dem präsidenten
verteidigen und am ende kommt es dann
zur abstimmung und da ist eine
zweidrittel mehrheit nötig im senat an
dieser zwei drittel mehr ist das letzte
amtsenthebungsverfahren gescheitert
diesmal könnten die chancen größer sein
dass mehr republikaner überlaufen zu den
demokraten es gibt ja bereits drei
republikanische senatoren die sogar den
rücktritt von donald trump gefordert
haben
deshalb ist gibt es die chance dass es
doch zu einem impeachment kommen könnte
da der anreiz wieder republikaner könnte
sein dass aufgrund eines impeachment
dann auch klar gestellt ist das land
haben nie wieder kandidieren darf das
heißt seine pläne von einer neuerlichen
antreten jahr 2024 während zunichte
gemacht lieber wäre es in demokratisches
angesprochen herbert natürlich wenn
donald trump freiwillig zurücktreten
würde oder aber wenn mike pence
das ganze verfahren jetzt anstoßen würde
wie wahrscheinlich ist das
ein rücktritt ist de facto derzeit
ausgeschlossen dass er donald trump
bereits klargemacht ganz im gegenteil
was man jetzt hört plant der präsident
sogar praktisch eine kleine ehrenrunde
durch die usa wo er die errungenschaften
seiner präsidentschaft hervorkehren
möchte da ist etwa möglicherweise ein
trip nach texas zu mexiko mauer geplant
das ganze wird natürlich sehr bezahl
erwirken wenn der wenn donald trump er
diese ehrenrunde dreht was mike pence
betrifft hat der vize-präsident
klargestellt dass er einen schritt gegen
donald trump nicht ganz ausgeschlossen
hat bisher oder ausschließen will es
geht dabei um den 25 zusatzartikel der
amerikanischen verfassung wo ein
präsident für amtsunfähig erklärt werden
kann die initiative dabei muss der
vize-präsident ergreifen und er braucht
dafür acht mitglieder des kabinetts dann
wäre donald trump praktisch abgesetzt
mike pence würde die macht übernehmen
was schmackhaft sein könnte für donald
trump bei diesen schritt ja natürlich
sehr schmachvoll ist wäre die tatsache
dass mike pence donald trump dann
begnadigen könnte es falls er das tut
soll eine solche begnadigung würde dem
präsidenten weit besser schützen als
eine selbst begnadigung die donald trump
ebenfalls ins in erwägung gezogen hat in
zehn tagen ist die ära trank dennoch
erst einmal vorbei lohnt sich das alles
dann überhaupt noch
es gibt auch stimmen die gegen das im
pitch mend argumentieren und zwar viele
konservative medien experten und un
experten auch politiker die sagen das
würde rüberkommen wie ein bloßer
racheakt der demokraten an donald trump
bundes wäre auch die gefahr groß dass
man donald trump hier zum märtyrer
machen könnte das sind stimmen die
praktisch zur moderation aufrufen auch
lindsay graham ein ehemaliger
unterstützer von donald trump hat sich
hier zu wort gemeldet man darf nicht
vergessen
viele sehr viele menschen stehen noch
hinter donald trump des landes gespalten
wie noch nie und wie
wie furchtbar die stimmung eigentlich
ist in amerika ist auch zu sehen an
einem vorfall der sie geeignet hat hier
in new york aber im holocaust-museum das
liegt genau gegenüber von der schule in
dem die meine eigene tochter geht an
diesem jahr in diesem holocaust memorial
wurde eine rassistische konfigurations
plagge aufgehängt das alles sind
anzeichen wie explosiv explosiv und
vergiftet die stimmung derzeit ist in
amerika
wir haben zwanzigster januar wird dann
joe biden in sein neues amt eingeführt
die inauguration die übertragen wie hier
bei bild natürlich live und damit
herzlichen dank herr bei dauernebel für
deine einschätzungen aus den usa mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren